bonjour à tous bienvenue à vous si vous
nous rejoignez on continue la matinée
ensemble sur sud radio jusqu'à midi dans
le grand référendum semin ce matin
françois hollande doit-il oui ou non se
représenter en 2,2 en 2010 est je vous
aurais posé la question il ya trois mois
certains que beaucoup d'entre vous y
compris à gauche aurait tout de suite
signé mais la donne a un petit peu
changé depuis les attentats surfant sur
cet esprit du 11 janvier le président de
la république a repris quelques couleurs
dans les sondages mais pas assez
peut-être encore pour s'assurer de
l'emporter dans deux ans et justement le
président a eu cette phrase énigmatique
hier pendant sa conférence de presse il
nous a dit que s'il n'atteignait pas ses
objectifs il ne pourrait pas être
candidat dans deux ans drôle de phrase
dans la bouche du chef de l'état en tout
cas ce serait une première dans
l'histoire de la vème si le président de
la république rendait son tablier avant
de repasser devant les électeurs et ça
arrangerait peut-être beaucoup de monde
y compris au parti socialiste alors
françois hollande doit-il oui ou non se
représenter en 2017 je vous attends au 0
826 303 sans vous nous appelez pour dire
ce que vous en pensez vous votez
également sur sud radio point fr et puis
vos messages sur les réseaux sociaux la
page facebook de sud radio twitter avec
le mot clé sud radio enfin par sms aussi
sud un espace votre message que vous
nous envoyez au 71 de sol
sud radio dimitri pavlenko
le grand référendum le grand référendum
sud radio apprendre et comprendre
françois hollande doit-il oui ou non se
représenter en 2017 vous votez sur sud
radio point fr et je vous attends au 0
826 300 320 en débattre avec nos invités
ce matin thomas guénolé politologue dans
quelques minutes et marielle de sarnez
députée européenne modem alexis bachelet
député ps de la première circonscription
des hauts-de-seine bonjour à tous les
deux alexis bachelet je commence par
vous françois hollande selon vous
doit-il se représenter en 2017
bonjour
oui je pense que françois hollande en
tout cas je l'espère devra se
représenter en 2017 alors c'est quoi ça
c'est quoi ce we alexis baechler vous
sent un peu hésitants malgré tout c'est
la ligne officielle du ps ou votre
conviction sincère
non ma conviction profonde c'est que
françois hollande est en train de mener
une action
importante au service du pays je crois
qu'il a lui-même fixé les objectifs de
son mandat le redressement économique
faire reculer le chômage
resserrer les liens entre les français
resteraient l'autorité de l'état
remettre live de laïcité aussi au coeur
de notre projet de société je crois que
les objectifs sont nombreux il y
travaille il a été confronté en ce début
d'année à des événements dramatiques qui
ont pu faire sentir aux français à quel
point il était capable de prendre ses
responsabilités capable de tenir une
situation de tension extrême
le d'inquiétude angoisses et ont
tous souhaité pour notre pays c'est que
effectivement les grands objectifs qu'il
a fixés depuis le début de son
quinquennat il aurait affirmé je dirais
de manière externe notamment à travers
ses conférences de presse sont des
moments aussi toute transparence de
compte rendu aux français ils s'y
étaient engagés et il tient
régulièrement ses conférences de presse
je crois que c'est le chemin qu'il faut
qu'il faut continuer à tenir
alors sur les objectifs alexis bachelet
là vous vous en oeuvre nous avait fait
une énumération de ses objectifs je vous
cite la une du parisien du jour et les
chômeurs monsieur le président et les
chômeurs il n'en a pas du tout parlé la
lutte contre le chômage qui reste pour
beaucoup de français je repense sondage
du 1er janvier ça reste la priorité
numéro un des français il n'y a eu
aucune annonce en la matière hier
oui mais ça moi je pense que je dirais
parce que les décisions
économiques qui ont été prises depuis le
début du quinquennat elles vont pas être
remise à jour tous les six mois quand on
fait effectivement le pack de
responsabilités et qu'on apporte
de l'aide à nos entreprises à ça à
travers un certain nombre de dispositifs
fiscaux à travers aussi la
simplification administrative
tout ce travail là il est en cours on
attend les attaques de responsabilité à
l'exceptionnelle son amendement pourrait
enfin je veux dire je pense que les
français comprennent que en matière
d'économie on peut pas d'abord changer
de cap tous les six mois et une fois
qu'on a mené 1-4 en place il faut le
tenir pour que les effets et les
objectifs soient atteints donc là je
pense que de ce point de vue là tu as
quand même pas très sérieux si tous les
six mois à chaque conférence de presse
présentant république faisait des
annonces nouvelles ou différentes tout
ce qui a été décidé il ya plusieurs mois
et qui nous restait en tous va produire
ses effets simplement il ya aussi un
élément de contexte et que cette
conférence de presse elle intervient
dans à la fois dans un climat national
particulier suite aux événements aux
attentats de l'année et au sursaut
républicain du 11 janvier et aussi dans
un contexte international particulier la
guerre est à nos portes en europe gare
effectivement une intensification du
conflit également aux morilles royan ma
france est présente également en afrique
sur plusieurs théâtres d'opérations donc
c'est aussi normal que l'intervention du
président de la république soit adaptée
au contexte et aux aux enjeux au sujet
du moment avec nous également marielle
de sarnez bonjour maynor députée
européenne modem on a vous avez écouté
du coup françois hollande y est
pour cette 5e conférence de presse je
les mêmes regardez vous l'avez même
regarder formidable alors marielle de
sarnez ce président de la république
était fortement contestée y compris dans
ses rangs les frondeurs dont on parlait
beaucoup avant noël on les entend plus
trop aujourd'hui pensez vous que la
donne a changé aujourd'hui pour françois
hollande dans la perspective de 2017
peut-il aujourd'hui légitimement se
représenter d'après vous dans deux ans
et demi moi je pense que la question
n'est pas petit loup doit-il c'est que
je crois que dans la logique de la vème
république il est toujours pensé même
quand il était très très bas dans les
sondages la logique de la cinquième
c'est que le président sortant se
représente
donc moi j'ai toujours pensé que quelque
chose le lendemain avait envie se
représenter avait envie de se
représenter et ferait tout pour se
représenter ça c'est la première chose
deuxième chose un mot sur sa conférence
de presse un mot au fond sur la suite
des événements terribles de ce début du
mois de janvier
moi je lui donne un satisfecit sur la
manière dont il a géré la séquence sur
la manière dont la france fait face et
fera face en europe et avec l'europe sur
la question du terrorisme de ce point de
vue là je lui donne aussi un satisfecit
sur la manière dont il gère la politique
étrangère je trouve que l'initiative
qu'il a prise avec angela merkel est une
bonne initiative de partir on a cru à
tous si elle réussira si elle débouchera
mais pendant qu'on a un john kerry qui
est en ukraine pour éventuellement
vendre des armes entre guillemets aux
ukrainiens donner toutes ses chances à
une diplomatie conjointe de l'allemagne
et de la france c'est bien
françois mitterrand il ya 30 ans avec la
nouvelle calédonie même ainsi conférence
de presse il par le lendemain c'est bien
c'est bien là je trouve qu'il est à la
hauteur de la fonction du chef d'état
bon en revanche si vous m'interrogez sur
la politique intérieure là je considère
qu'il y a au fond une absence et une
absence d'ambition et de vision dans les
objectifs dans les perspectives pour
notre pays et que les réponses ne sont
pas du tout à la hauteur mais ça c'est
le débat politique maël de sanaa
marianne2 est-ce que c'est normal qu'on
se pose la question politique sont des
fesses à ce que je viens de dire oui
mais est-ce que c'est normal de se poser
la question y compris dans les rangs des
socialistes n'en parlera tout à l'heure
de se poser la question de savoir si
françois hollande doit se représenter ça
c'est le problème des socialistes
j'allais dire moi je vous dis dans la
logique de la cinquième la logique c'est
que le président de la république ya
jamais eu de précédent différend 1 sauf
quand mitterrand est partie évidemment
au bout de deux mandats c'est que le
président de la république sortant ben
il a envie quand il y est d'y rester
voilà ça s'est toujours passé comme ça
après moi je trouve que ce qui est
intéressant c'est qu'on prenne un peu de
hauteur et qu'on regarde au fond qu'est
ce qui sera bon pour la france à la
prochaine élection présidentielle
et si je vous dis ça c'est que au fond
malgré la remontée françois hollande
malgré les qualités des uns ou des
autres moi j'ai le sentiment qu'il y a
aujourd'hui quand il se pose la question
de l'élection présidentielle est
lointaine il ya beaucoup de choses qui
vont arriver avant donc faut faire
attention de pas faire de politique
fiction en même temps ce que je ressens
c'est qu'il ya des millions de français
qui ont pas envie de rejouer le match de
la dernière fois il ya des millions de
français qui ont pas envie au fond de
revoir françois hollande et nicolas
sarkozy dans un match de surcroît
arbitré par marine le pen alors c'est
toute la question des politiques qui
pensent qu'au fond ces millions de
français ils ont envie d'autre chose que
peut-être il faut une élection
présidentielle la prochaine fois qu'ils
sortent de l'ordinaire qui n'oppose pas
un camp à un autre avec des promesses
qui sont faites et qui sont au fond
jamais tenues qui apporte de la
désespérance dans le pays depuis 30 ans
peut-être qu'il faut un chemin nouveau
en tout cas moi je mettrai toute mon
énergie
de mon côté au centre avec mes amis a
essayé d'esquisser ce chemin nouveau
alexis bachelez comment vous interpréter
cette phrase de françois hollande que
c'est un introduction si je n'atteins
pas mes objectifs je ne pourrais pas
être candidat dans deux ans c'est quoi
c'est une prise de conscience
qui ne pourra pas tenir certaines de ses
promesses de 2012 où est-ce que c'est
l'intérêt supérieur de son camp
finalement qui primera pour savoir qui
sera le bon champion dans deux ans et
demi pour les socialistes
c'est la prise de conscience de la
fragilité la tragédie vite et enfin de
la fragilité de la parole publique et de
la défiance aussi des français vis-à-vis
de cette parole publique et je crois que
s'il est effectivement il répète parce
que ce n'est pas la première fois qu'il
le dit lors d'une intervention publique
il s'engage sur effectivement la
réussite le retournement économique la
conjoncture économique et s'il met virer
son destin personnel dans la balance
c'est parce qu'ils pensent que c'est le
combat principal donc ça renvoie aussi à
votre question de tout à l'heure sur ed
que on a suffisamment parlé des
questions économiques et de chômage je
crois que c'est vraiment là la toile de
fond le fil conducteur depuis le début
du quinquennat je vais pas dire qu'au
début du quinquennat n'y a pas eu des
tâtonnements et peut-être des italiens
sur la stratégie et les choix politiques
c'est tourner a constaté et je crois que
ça faisait partie peut-être des
critiques qu'on pouvait porter
quinquennat alexis bachelet sur sa
personne ce que disait marielle de
sarnez est très vrai il ya beaucoup de
français qui ont pas envie de revoir le
match de 2012 françois hollande contre
nicolas sarkozy a arbitré par marine le
pen laisse que le casting doit pas
changer pour cette simple raison de
bases savoir que les français n'en
veulent pas mais moi je pense qu'il faut
prendre le problème à l'envers c'est à
dire que cette élection présidentielle l
ultra personnalisés les débats on est
sur la cravate de travers on est sur tel
ou tel comportement alors il ya eu des
comportements qui ont pu choquer
notamment dans le quinquennat presse
précédent de la part d'un président de
la république peut-être que certains
tentent n apprécie pas tel ou tel
comportement de l'actuel président mais
est ce que oui aussi d'enfants sont
morts dans la sphère jus dans la liesse
a pas été très bonnes séquences en fait
franchement que l'avenir de du pays
dépend de la manière dont on porte une
cravate ou de tel ou tel détail non moi
je pense que l'avenir du pays c'est des
grands choix des grandes orientations et
surtout des résultats 3 que ce que les
français attendent c'est de l'efficacité
si l'efficacité elle n'est pas au rendez
vous il est clair qu'il ya un problème
de crédibilité de la parole publique
sera suffisamment que dit le président
de la république à travers ses
déclarations successives maintenant moi
je vais vous dire je pense que l'autre
problème dont on souffre en france une
idée de ces institutions
binaire ont effectivement au deuxième
tour c'est la droite contre la gauche
parfois même la droite et l'extrême
droite ça pourrait être vous ce coup là
justement alexis match et on va en
reparler un peu plus tard dans dans
l'émission clair un message aux
standards vous nous lire et ça peut-être
juste après la pl publicité on marque
une très courte pause je vous rappelle
la question du grand référendum du jour
faut-il oui ou non que françois hollande
se représente en 2010 est qu'en pensez
vous sera-t-il le bon candidat pour la
gauche dans deux ans candidat à sa
propre succession va accueillir thomas
guénolé dans un petit instant
politologue le grand référendum se
poursuit juste après la pub a tout de
suite sud radio dimitri pavlenko
le grand référendum le grand référendum
sud radio apprendre et comprendre
françois hollande doit-il oui ou non se
représenter en 2017 j'attends vos appels
un venu nous en parler 0 826 trois cents
300 vos messages sur la page facebook de
sud radio sur twitter et vous votez sur
sud radio points ont fait point fr où
vous pouvez également nous laisser vos
commentaires on en débat avec alexis
bachelet député ps de la première
circonscription des hauts-de-seine
marielle de sarnez députée européenne
modem et thomas guénolé qui nous rejoint
bonjour thomas
alors avant peut-être de vous donner la
parole ce message qu'ils nous aient
laissé par patrick un auditeur cas c'est
intéressant allez-y clair oui c'est un
message qui dit ce serait très bien que
hollande ce prêt se représente car il
maintient une bonne cohérence dans le
pays en revanche ce qu'on peut lui
reprocher c'est de ne pas choisir le bon
premier ministre voilà pierre jetée dans
le jardin de manuel valls thomas guénolé
alors évidemment peut-on parler de
françois hollande de sa son éventuelle
candidature à sa propre succession en
2010 est sans parler de manuel valls
sans parler du premier ministre de ce
couple exécutif
ben et je dirais plutôt peut-on parler
de l'identité du futur candidat du parti
socialiste
fort mentionné qu'il doit y avoir une
primaire
ce débat sur la primaire qu'on avait
déjà eu et qui est théoriquement est
inscrit dans les statuts du parti
socialiste
mémoire effectivement dans les statuts
du parti socialiste et à l'écrit battez
vous le confirmera sans doute
l'article 5 3 1 des statuts prévoit
toujours que le candidat du parti
socialiste à l'élection présidentielle
est désigné par une primaire ouverte
c'est-à-dire à laquelle toute personne
qui souhaite venir voter peut voter et à
laquelle tous partis de gauche dit veut
pas rejoindre peut se joindre et il n'y
a aucune exception qui soient mentionnés
il n'y a en particulier il n'est pas
marqué dans les statuts que si le
président de la république et sortants
pardon si le président de la république
sortant et membre du ps et veut se
représenter il est dispensé de primaires
ce cas là n'est pas prévu donc je à ma
connaissance le parti socialiste est un
parti qui qui a à coeur de respecter ses
propres statuts je suppose que monsieur
bachelot ici présent vous confirmera et
donc il y aura bien une primaire donc
quand vous me dites est ce que hollande
est ce que valent ces avancées
présentées 1017 faudra d'abord qu'il se
présente à la primaire du parti
socialiste vous dit thomas guénolé ou
alors le
voyez bien
marielle de sarnez c'est vrai que c'est
un peu quelque part le piège aujourd'hui
de ce système des primaires auxquelles
le ps théoriquement doit se plier avant
de proposer un candidat à l'élection
présidentielle de 2017 on élude un peu
la question aujourd'hui c'est vrai qu'on
n'en parle pas du tout alors que c'était
prévu dans les statuts du parti moi je
ne crois pas un mot de sa c'est
évidemment dans les statuts thomas
guénolé a raison c'est un observateur
très très fin de notre vie politique
mais je ne crois pas du tout que ça va
se passer de cette façon là c'est à dire
je crois que l'esprit au fond de nos
institutions de notre constitution
s'imposera et sera je n'en doute pas
plus fort que la simple écriture des
statuts du parti socialiste
au fond un président de la république
sortant il va pas aller sur les tréteaux
dans les départements français pendant
trois mois ou six mois dans les
fédérations comme menées dans les
fédérations socialistes alors qu'il est
président de la république en exercice
que le monde est ce qu'il est les
déstabilisations source quelles sont les
menaces sont ce qu'elles sont à
l'extérieur à l'intérieur ce serait mal
je lui consacre du temps je ne crois pas
une seconde à cette hypothèse mais si je
peux me permettre de rebondir votre
habité disais tout à l'heure avant que
thomas guaino line s'exprime qui avait
un problème avec nos institutions je le
rejoins il a parfaitement raison nous
avons des institutions qui installe ont
installé une espèce de bipolarisation
clivante droite contre gauche gauche
contre droite on est au gouvernement
l'opposition vous dit tout ce que vous
faites est nul l'opposition revient au
gouvernement a dit que tout ce qu'on
fait les prêts ses prédécesseurs étaient
absolument nul ce qui fait depuis 30 ans
on n'avance pas on recule et ce qui fait
depuis 30 ans le seul qui avance et le
front national et donc il faudra bien
qu'un jour et j'ai regretté de ce point
de vue là françois hollande se soit
échappé hier soir cela elle forme des
institutions cette réforme elle est
indispensable
on a une démocratie en bout du bout de
souffle mais on n'en a pas
non mais on a besoin de diminuer notre
bonne chose concrète n'a besoin de
diminuer notre nombre de députés de
sénateurs ils sont trop nombreux il vaut
mieux - de parlementaires qui passe bien
le job on a besoin de repenser
l'équilibré du pouvoir entre le
parlement et le pouvoir exécutif et on a
besoin d pardonnez moi de le dire que le
pluralisme s'exerce à l'assemblée
nationale aujourd'hui on a grosso modo
deux parties qui font 90 ou 95% des
sièges et qui représente même pas 50
pour que ça soit au détriment des
dessertes intérieures
du centre et d'autre et bien pardonnez
moi les démocraties ne peuvent pas
fonctionner de cette manière là bon
alors en tout cas avant qu'on avance sur
sept ce chapitre institutionnel
justement alexis bachelet en rebond sur
ce que disait thomas guénolé et la
primaire dans tout ça a prévu par les
statuts du ps françois hollande doit-il
se représenter en 2017 françois hollande
doit-il avant se soumettre aux primaires
du parti socialiste
outre thomas geha rappeler ce que sont
les statuts de notre parti et le fait
qu'il ya une primaire qui est désormais
inscrite non seulement les statuts du
parti socialiste mais aussi je crois
qu'ils pourraient faire partie de notre
nouvelle culture démocratique est
effectivement c'était confirmé à chaque
à chaque élection est ce qu'il ya une
occasion là de donner l'exemple
justement alexis bachelet sur cette idée
de respecter à noël je rappelle souvent
que là où les primaires ont été
entretenues mais inventer ou en tout cas
la zone traduction monteiro seat à tous
y compris le président obama est soumis
à des primaires alors sphère informelle
institutions ni la même constitution
de tout le système des primaires a été
inventé pour sélectionner le candidat à
la présidentielle
donc y compris dans les formations de
l'opposition
du côté de l'ump on a décidé de mettre
aussi un système de primaires en place
donc après moi je veux pas faire de la
politique fiction je ne sais pas
françois hollande sera candidat à sa
succession
je ne peux donc pas s'il soumettra à des
primaires et les scénarios sont divers
alexis bachelet ça pose quand même une
vraie question ce que vous dites vous ne
savez pas si françois hollande se
soumettra à la primaire vous parlez
d'exemplarité précisément
non mais voilà c'est vrai mais il
n'évoque lui même pas le cas de la
primaire alors là ça pose une vraie
question parce que d'un ça serait
sûrement mal compris des français qu'ils
consacrent du temps à une élection
interne finalement alors qu'il est
président la république mais de l'autre
s'ils jouent pas le jeu de la primaire
quelque part et bien il s'affranchit des
institutions qu'il a lui-même contribué
à mettre en place c'est compliqué là
quand même absolument il ya donc une
forme de contradiction paradoxal qu'il
faudra à surmonter moi je veux vous dire
ma position de principal est assez
simple et fois je suis favorable à ce
que les primaires soient maintenues et
si possible élargi à toute la gauche
pour donner dès le premier tour une
véritable assise au candidat de la
gauche éviter que ne se reproduise le 21
avril 2002 voilà après moi j'en fais pas
une question de personne encore une fois
personne ne tait on est encore loin de
l'élection de 2017 peut se passer
beaucoup de choses on l'a vécu ces
derniers jours dernières semaines on a
vécu des événements hors normes
auxquelles on n'était
pas forcément on a su y répondre mais
j'étais des événements enfin on a quand
même des textes des institutions y
compris au ps qui théoriquement
permettrait d'avoir comme une idée du
scénario à venir thomas guénolé ça vous
surprend ce que dit alexis bachelet pas
à propos justement de ces primaires au
ps dont on ne parle plus finalement qui
serait en fait le jeu de du candidat de
l'opposition finalement les primaires
c'est bien quand on est dans
l'opposition on pas quand on est au
pouvoir
je dirais plutôt au parlement mais met
enfin en l'occurrence c'est intéressant
aussi de soulever cette question là
thomas guénolé mais ce que visiblement
il y aurait il y aura une primaire à
droite ça c'est à peu près acté mais pas
de primaires à gauche prévu le parti au
pouvoir joue pas forcément le jeu des
primaires ah pardon je n'étais pas au
courant
mais ça s'est jamais fait ça sait jamais
et alors c'est marqué dans les statuts
c'est l'occasion de le faire don mais je
ne voudrais surtout pas passer pour un
abruti borné mais règlement on est prêt
c'est ou alors qu'on m'explique que le
parti socialiste qui est l'un des grands
partis du pays a l'intention de 2
comment dire de violer ses propres
statuts non je veux dire y'a quand même
là tu une question qu'il faut sauver je
remercie d'ailleurs alexis d'avoir
répondu avec beaucoup de clarté en ce
qui le concerne à titre personnel
après moi j'aimerais qu'ils la même
clarté que celle dont lui-même fait
preuve du côté de la direction du parti
socialiste et du côté du conseil
national du parti s'il y est c'est parce
que
ce serait quand même ce serait quand
même lamentable que cette question soit
réglée à la dernière minute de manière
salle plus ou moins acrobatique et plus
ou moins bâclé les deux pire chose qui
pourrait arriver ce serait que à la
dernière minute ce soit soumis en
loucedé si vous me passez l'expression
un vote du congrès qui va arriver engins
là le congrès de poitiers si ma mort est
bonne de modifier la procédure nous
convainc du temps des socialistes 1 mais
voilà le congrès du parti socialiste qui
doit avoir lieu au mois de juin ça se
ferait un peu sale mais bon ce serait
bien de l'annoncer avant au moins au
moins deux au moins un mois avant si
vous voulez des amis a offerte il faut
modifier la procédure ou alors encore
pire c'est de faire une décision qui
ferait en fait contraire aux procédures
internes je vous donne un exemple parce
que ça s'est déjà produit dans
l'histoire du ps c'est le conseil
national mais c'est à dire le parlement
du parti pour résumer n'est pas
compétent pour prendre ce genre de
décision mais il s'assoit sur les
statuts et il prend quand même la
décision en l'occurrence ne pas faire de
primaire mais donc ce débat doit être
soulevée ne serait ce que parce que
mettez-vous de seconde à la place des
adhérents du parti socialiste qui ont
adopté par leur vote et les adhérents
eux mêmes qui ont voté ça il y aurait
des primaires est derrière va écouter
les enfants on va faire autre chose
n'est pas très sérieux marielle de
sarnez sur ce principe des primaires
c'est quand même être très intéressant
ce que dit thomas guénolé c'est à dire
que dans la politique en france il ya
les textes qui régissent normalement le
fonctionnement de la vie politique et il
ya la pratique finalement ben écoutez on
verra ça vraiment je n'ai pas beau
chapitre suis pas militante du parti
socialiste c'est une affaire qui regarde
le parti socialiste les statuts d'un
parti par définition c'est sûr c'est
leur affaire moi je vous ai pas d'esprit
des institutions de la vème république
je ne crois pas du tout réaliste mais
pas du tout mais peut-être on verra
peut-être les faits me démentiront je
m'excuse écouter les faits n'ont démenti
je ne crois pas du tout à ça je crois
pas du tout à cette hypothèse dans le
cas où le président de la république
sortant se représente mais j'ai passé
refait un mari est ce que les français
attendent de françois hollande si on
informe institutionnels à bessèges sceau
d'un certain que les français attendent
des primaires matin midi et soir je
pense que les français attendent de
responsables politiques qu'ils arrêtent
de leur mentir qu'ils arrêtent de faire
des promesses qui sont intenables qu'ils
arrêtent de s'étriper camp hollande est
inventeur pour vous mariez de salaire
non mais tous les hommes politiques
depuis trente ans en campagne on dit un
certain nombre de choses qui derrière
n'ont jamais été tenues c'est ça qui
fait l'explosion du front national vous
aussi planter du front national n'a
jamais c'est peut-être pour ça que
françois bayrou n'a pas été élu ce qu'on
a dit la vérité exacte sur au fond les
difficultés du pays les remèdes qu'il
fallait apporter voilà moi je souhaite
que la présidentielle la prochaine fois
soit réussie c'est à dire que celui
celle qui sera élu et qui sera 100 tours
et ensuite d'une équipe s'attelle
vraiment ou difficultés de la france
répondent vraiment aux attentes des
français retrouve une efficacité
politique renoue avec une forme de
confiance et pour ça c'est vrai qu'il
faut faire bouger aussi les lignes qu'il
faut faire bouger les institutions vous
comprenez la bipolarisation c'est simple
c'est vachement confortable vous avez un
parti au pouvoir l'autre il peut être
nulle et pète mauvais il peut n'avoir
aucune idée ne pas faire travailler
intellectuelle toute façon
automatiquement il sait qu'il va revenir
au pouvoir et ainsi de suite et ça fait
30 ans que ça dure ben moi je souhaite
que la prochaine élection présidentielle
soit une élection d'adhésion et qu'on
n'est pas des candidats qui seraient
élus éventuellement par défaut et ça
pour moi c'est vraiment ce qui est plus
important alors vous parlez du mans sont
justement thomas gueydan les petits
coups de pub c'est aujourd'hui que vous
décernez votre prix du mentor en
politique je note que françois hollande
ne fait pas partie de
de la liste des nominés justement pour
le coup n'est pas pris en défaut sur ce
chapitre là de la parole non tenue ou du
mensonge éhonté il ne faut pas confondre
la promesse non tenue avec le fait
d'avoir menti car ce n'est pas la même
chose par ailleurs le prix du le prix
2014 du mentor en politique qui a été
décernée par ce que il a été décerné ce
matin le communiqué de paris mentionnera
pas eu la primeur du coup puisque sa
dette s'est communiquée mais rappelez
nous qui a gagné du coup si je puis dire
à vous êtes vous serez probablement vous
êtes la première personne à qui je dis à
la radio en tout cas effectivement le
vainqueur et nicolas sarkozy ah ben
bravo cette correction gagner pour lui
pour ses 17 mensonges répétés en boucle
pendant la campagne d'élection à la
présidence de l'ump il ya cependant des
prix spéciaux jérôme cahuzac a reçu un
prix spécial pour l'ensemble de sa
carrière
il ya eu qui également un prix un
certain regard qui a été décerné à jean
pierre juillet pour sa créativité en
ayant inventé en ayant inventé le
démenti de son propre démenti et puis
vous avez le prix jeune espoir qui a été
remis à guillaume pelletier parce que le
jury a estimé que c'était un menteur
extrêmement prometteur par rapport à
fendre jeune âge bon voilà encore une
bipolarité gosses droite si je puis dire
donc je rappelle que la saisie dans le
cas aux usa jean-pierre juillet
guillaume pelletier non pardon mais les
nominés jean luc mélenchon pour les pour
ses dénégations éhontée de son
absentéisme au parlement européen alors
qu'il est absentéistes parlement
européen vous avez marine le pen ait été
nominé pour une série d'approximations
et d'exagérations sur l'immigration le
djihadisme enfin plus généralement
thomas guénolé c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui
le mensonge en politique ça fait très
mal aujourd'hui ça fait très mal
alors en fait pour moi la situation du
mensonge en politique est à peu près la
même que celle que la corruption en
politique ce n'est pas qu'il y en a plus
c'est que c'est beaucoup plus détecté
déconstruit et dévoilée par telle ou
telle rubrique spécialisée ou tel ou tel
média spécialisé dans le paysage
médiatique
les le personnel politique d'il ya 50
ans n'était pas moins menteur et
n'étaient pas moins corrompus il était
même probablement davantage c'était
moins à surveiller ces thèmes ont repris
le mans c'était moins surveillés et
moins des balles et puis il faut dire ce
qui est les médias à l'époque était
beaucoup moins libre qu'aujourd'hui ils
ne le sont pas encore totalement
notamment parce que tout média un
actionnaire mais quand même ils sont
beaucoup plus libres que tant de coke au
bon vieux temps de la rtm et je vous
donne un exemple un scandale de
corruption l'expo la corruption un
scandale comme seul le scandale de
panama vous aviez la quasi intégralité
du parlement qui était trempe qui avait
trempé dans le scandale de corruption
pour des grands travaux concernant le
canal de panama c'est impensable
aujourd'hui aujourd'hui un mini un
député se trompe de casse dans sa
déclaration fiscale il le canard
enchaîné
alexis bachelet petit commentaire sur ce
palmarès du prix du mentor en politique
manuel valls aussi faisait partie des
nominés
alors qu'elle ne peut pas justement par
définition bon bonne nouvelle pour la
gauche finalement lexsi bachelez la
gauche ne peut pas mourir aussi
facilement que cela mais pour rebondir
par rapport à françois hollande on
pourra toujours effectivement lui lui ne
pas là on pourra pas lui reprocher
finalement d'avoir été pris en flagrant
délit de mensonge qui serait pas en 2014
oui mais ce qui serait plus en doute la
chose la plus grave pour un président en
exercice quand même alexis bachet
on vous entend c'est maxime ashley si
vous pouvez parler de plus devant votre
combiné oui
ne fera pas eu la preuve de l'engagement
dont on est parent trap enfin le monde
entre 1 et contraintes qui entravent
nova mais plus importante au
niveau de la complexité juridique le
rapport à lyon dont il veut seulement
locale et l'aimé pas
mais on entend de transparence peut
jouer un rôle et
autres
wii à l'assaut on en parle
sorte de romantisme
oui c'est tout mais sa logique d'aider
des promesses de campagne non tenues et
alors ça on va continuer à parler du cas
de françois hollande dans ce grand
référendum jour appelle la question du
jour doit-il se représenter en 2017
thomas guénolé nous rappeler ce petit
détail qui a son importance à savoir que
théoriquement et bien il doit y avoir
une primaire quel que soit le cas de
figure au pouvoir ou pas au parti
socialiste il doit y avoir une primaire
à laquelle théoriquement françois
hollande devrait se soumettre selon les
statuts du ps quand pensez-vous cette
primaire cela vous intéresserait-il d'y
participer vous votez sur sud radio
point fr à 0 826 trois cents 300 si vous
souhaitez prendre la parole à l'antenne
nous sommes avec alexis bachelet député
ps des hauts-de-seine marielle de sarnez
députée européenne modem merci thomas
guénolé d'avoir été avec nous
à la prochaine vous restez avec nous
revient dans un petit instant tout de
suite hein
sud radio dimitri pavlenko le grand
référendum le grand référendum sud radio
françois hollande doit-il se représenter
en 2017 doit-il faire cette primaire au
sein du parti socialiste au rythme prévu
par les statuts du parti on en parle
avec alexis bachelet député ps de la
première circonscription des
hauts-de-seine et marielle de sarnez
députée européenne modem marielle de
sarnez
précisément si on regarde un petit peu
en arrière il n'y a pas très longtemps
de cela il ya 2 ou 3 - on entendait
l'opposition a appelé françois hollande
à la démission bon jusque là rien que de
très normal mais également dans son
propre camp je me souviens d'une
interview donnée par michel rocard qui
déconseillait à françois hollande
c'était en octobre dernier de se
représenter à ce moment là manuel valls
eux étaient plutôt qu'au repos en disant
bas 90 françois hollande serait le
candidat naturel mais ya quand même des
voix à gauche qui disait attention
françois hollande ne doit pas forcément
se représenter en 2017 c'est un trop
grand risque pour la gauche marielle de
sarnez c'est assez inédit ça quand même
un dans l'histoire le savez la politique
c'est un condensé de l'humain est donc
au four les hommes sont assez faibles et
assez fragile donc quand ils voient que
leurs leaders ne va pas bien que ce
qu'ils font plutôt que de le soutenir
ben aziza là il faut absolument qu'il
s'en aille qu'il se barre qu'il se
représente pas le courage en politique
est malheureusement assez rare moi je
crois qu'il faut pas avoir le nez sur
les événements de court terme qu'il faut
essayer d'avoir une réflexion qui est
plus le long terme de regarder l'intérêt
général de regarder d'avoir d'avoir une
vision un peu plus large je vous redis
que je crois pas un instant à déprimer à
vous imaginer par exemple le président
de la république faisant des primaires
avec son premier ministre enfin vous est
ce que vous vous croyez qu'il faut pas
ça ce sera intéressant rôle oui c'est
très amusant un peu ras juste un peu de
bon sens de temps en temps dans le débat
politique on dit tellement de bêtises
pour être poli juste voilà du bon sens
eh ben ça n'est tout simplement pas
imaginable ou tel membre du gouvernement
se présentant contre président sortant
dans une primaire ça n'existe pas cette
hypothèse n'existe pas alexis bachelet
s'est donc
acté c'est bon il y aura pas de
primaires en 2016 ça n'est que mon avis
hein je suis pas au ps c'est à eux de
faire le ménage avant vous avez une
opinion quand même relativement tranché
marielle de sarnez et puis c'est vrai
vous avez raison c'est vrai que
objectivement il paraît peu crédible qui
est cette primaire alexis bachelet ce
serait quand même moi je trouve
l'honneur de la gauche finalement de
d'organiser cette primaire qui auraient
des déserts un peu bizarre si
effectivement le président la république
et son premier ministre se retrouvait
ainsi retrouvés en confrontation face
aux militants socialistes
ouais mais là je crois quand même qu'il
faut être un peu raisonnable et sérieux
on est dans la science fiction on ne
sait pas dans quelle situation
ne se trouvera le président de la
république l'année prochaine quels sont
les événements qui peuvent survenir
d'ici là il ya un congrès du parti
socialiste donc peut-être cette question
fera t-elle l'objet effectivement d'un
échange contradictoire entre nous et
peut-être que les statuts pourrait
évoluer enfin je veux dire objectivement
nous soyons sérieux il ya des sujets
extrêmement plus important en ce moment
à débattre que de savoir non mais il ya
toujours plus sérieux il ya toujours
plus importants alexis bachelet mais
regardée aux états unis par exemple près
de l'oeil alors même si c'est vrai que
c'est c'est une formalité mais le
président en exercice il repasse devant
les militants de son parti pour être
adoubé y compris sa propre réélection
c'est ça se passe systématiquement aux
etats unis c'est dans les moeurs
politiques américaines pourquoi ça
serait pas le cas chez nous écoutez moi
c'est déjà donné ma position je pense
que il faut inscrire les primaires
citoyennes dans 20 ans l'ont et donc
leur donner la possibilité de se
réaliser à chaque élection quel que soit
le contexte maintenant le contexte
importe aussi les statuts du parti c'est
important
la personnalité des candidats c'est
fondamental mais peut y avoir aussi des
éléments de contexte et je crois que le
début de l'année que nous venons de
vivre doit nous amener à a beaucoup
d'humilité et de modestie et donc je ne
pense pas qu'on puisse exprimer des
choses aussi tranchée
que soient effectivement le fait de dire
oui on est sûre à 200% qu'il y aura des
primaires ou non ce ne sera pas possible
je ne dis pas simplement bon le débat
reste ouvert le débat reste ouvert
d'accord alors marielle de sarnez ceci
dit maintenant sur la pratique du
pouvoir on a vu un françois hollande
hier fixer les grands caps les grands
objectifs
finalement un carnet davantage un
président de la république finalement
assez classique 1 c'est-à-dire
l'intendance suivra la mise en musique
finalement des grandes mesures annoncées
hier ce sera pour le gouvernement
c'est important pour françois hollande
vous pensez de reprendre un peu de
hauteur par rapport il compris aux
mesures qu'il est qu'il a proposé hier
vous pouvez reprendre de la hauteur mais
ça n'empêche pas d'essayer d'apporter
les bonnes réponses pour le pays moi je
crois qu'on a vraiment un problème
institutionnel je crois qu'on a aussi un
problème de la définition du rôle du
président moi je pense que d'abord le
président il doit pas être de gauche ou
de droite vous voyez doit être levé dans
la république de tous les français même
si vient d'une sensibilité qu'il a une
histoire ça c'est absolument normal mais
moi je pense que le président de la
république qui doit être au fond
représentant de l'union de cette unité
nationale qui n'empêche pas que des
courants politiques démocratiques
s'affontent pas du tout mais qui fait
que c'est un rôle un peu à part le
président de la république quand le gars
moi c'est ma c'est ma manière de le voir
le penser et dans ce rôle un peu à part
du client la public je crois qu'il a une
mission qui est au fond de montrer le
chemin de montrer la voie d'avoir une
vision de d'avoir des perspectives de
nous dire voilà peuple de france vers où
j'ai envie de vous emmener voilà vers où
nous allons et je trouve que de ce point
de vue là et bien les réponses ne sont
pas là si vous voulez sur le plan
économique ce plan social son plan des
réformes qui sont absolument nécessaires
pour le pays qui sont pas des réformes
pour que ça ait moins bien mais qui sont
des réformes pour que ça ait mieux
qu'ils sont des réformes pour qu'on
puisse est plus fort pour affronter au
fond le monde tel qu'il est et donc je
trouve que de ce point de vue là il me
semble dans cette séquence là de
perspectives en termes de politique
intérieure en termes regarder la
question de l'emploi on va arriver on
dépasse les 5 millions de chômeurs si on
inclut ceux qui sont à temps partiel
c'est une désespérance française c'est
un échec français regardez notre école
on recule année après année dans tous
les classements pisa et c'est pas de
remettre un petit peu d'argent de
refaire sur la table qui bar gay la
question on change et ça se sent et je
vais vous dire une chose c'est pas
depuis françois hollande tout ça c'est
depuis bien avant si on regarde au fond
le mandat nicolas sarkozy il n'y a pas
eu de réformes structurelles de fond si
on regarde le mandat de jacques chirac
il n'y a pas eu de réformes
structurelles de fond on n'a pas
amélioré notre politique notre éducation
nationale on a au fond autant de jeunes
qui malheureusement arrivent en sixième
sans maîtriser on sait bien le sens de
la lecture et des mots bon eh bien c'est
ça qu'on a devant nous et moi j'ai envie
qu'on affronte ça et je trouve que le
rôle d'un président la république ces
deux dire voilà les difficultés du pays
voilà comment on peut les affronter
voilà vers là où l'on doit aller mais je
pense que pour ça il faut aussi des
institutions qu'ils soient plus
efficaces que celles d'aujourd'hui et
est ce que vous pensez qu'un président
de la république ça doit aussi
reconnaître ses échecs quand ils n'y
arrivent pas sur le je pense que tout
être humain doit reconnaître ses échecs
et je pense que connaître des échecs de
toute façon quand vous les analyses et
bien ça vous permet de rebondir ça vous
permet d'avancer mais vous savez bien
françois hollande je pense qu'il a un
tempérament qui est qui est au fond
optimiste et qu'il se dit c'est
peut-être pas la peine de faire trop de
choses de bousculer et trop de choses
les choses vont s'arranger tout seul je
ne le crois pas je crois que si la
croissance revient elle reviendra pour
certains pays en europe avantage que de
briller davantage que pour d'autres pays
elle reviendra plus par exemple pour
l'allemagne ou pour des pays de l'europe
du nord que pour la france parce qu'on
n'a pas adapté au fond notre économie on
a aujourd'hui une économie sur
administrés il faut y mettre de la
souplesse il faut y mettre de la liberté
il faut prévoir il faut il faut rendre
possible la créativité il faut arrêter
de sueur administrés nos chefs
d'entreprises de petite et moyenne
entreprise on a un système bloqué en
france ce qu'il faut c'est débloquer
tout ça alexis bachelet sur 7
il est d'un assouplissement
d'un déblocage d'un président de la
république aussi qui semble attendre que
finalement le changement vienne de lui
même c'est à lui donc de prendre les
rênes d'entreprendre ses grandes
réformes quitte à travailler aussi avec
l'opposition cette idée là aussi on en a
parlé pendant le mois de janvier
l'esprit du 11 janvier c'est ça aussi
travailler main dans la main peut-être
avec l'opposition hmm hmm contre elle
parce qu'elle est pas toujours encline à
dire oui
j'apporterai quand même juste un léger
correctifs à ce que vient de dire
marielle de sarnez et notamment sur le
fait qu'au fond dans ce quinquennat il
n'y aurait pas de réforme d'ampleur pour
notre pays je crois que la réforme
territoriale que nous conduisons depuis
maintenant près de deux ans avec la
réduction du nombre de régions la mise
en avant des métropoles la
rationalisation de l'intercommunalité
les nouvelles compétences pour les
régions les départements qui dans
certains endroits ton appelées à
fusionner oua oua se voit se regrouper
je crois que ça sera une des grandes
réformes du quinquennat et une récente
d'ailleurs qui aurait dû être fait et là
je suis d'accord avec marielle de sarnez
depuis bien longtemps je crois que le
problème de la société française lui
c'est le décalage considérable entre une
classe politique archaïque
une culture du débat qui est parfois
proche du néant avec ces oppositions
factices
totalement artificielle entre la droite
et la gauche comme si la gauche ne
pouvait pas avoir des idées
intéressantes ou comme si la droite
n'avait je dirais que des mauvaises
propositions je crois tout ça c'est
profondément en décalage avec ce qui est
aujourd'hui la société française et que
malheureusement souvent la société
française ce christ et se braque au
moment de faire un certain nombre de
grands changements parce
qu'effectivement elle ne se reconnaît
pas dans la façon dont le débat
politique et dans la façon dont les
décisions sont prises je pense que
vraiment il ya un saut qualitatif à
faire que françois hollande alors
que les français se sentent mal
représentés alexis bachelet ce sont eux
n'avaient pas du tout représentés
finalement
une
une façon de vivre notre de la
démocratie dans notre pays qui est
totalement dépassé et qui surtout
n'était plus graves ne permet pas de
faire des réformes et ça fait 30 ans que
ça dure et finalement à force
effectivement de de se crisper de se
combattre jusqu'à l'épuisement les uns
contre les autres dans des blocs
extrêmement
extrêmement je dirais dur en les uns
envers les autres finalement ça fait
énergie front national qui sans avoir
aucune des solutions pour régler les
grands problèmes du pays surf sur les
chèques ou les difficultés des majorités
successives à résoudre les grands
problèmes du pays et ça ne remonte
effectivement pas à deux ans ça fait
plus de 25 ans cela dure c'est étonnant
mais rien de sain nationale vous avez un
discours assez proche du coup avec
alexis bachelet là pour le coup écoutez
si c'est un discours qui pouvait être
partagée par une majorité de la classe
politique j'en serais vraiment heureuse
il faut que cette classe politique elle
évolue elle bouge simplement je crains
qu'elle ne fasse pas par elle-même
loyers et donc c'est pour ça que je
pense que ça il revient aux bains aux
plus hautes autorités au président de la
république normalement bain de porter
cette vision là et d'avoir ce courage là
il
s'est échappé seul à être forme des
institutions je pense que c'est une
erreur
je pense que c'est très important qu'on
adapte nos institutions vous savez nous
sommes le seul pays d'europe qui est ce
mode de fonctionnement nous sommes le
seul pays d'europe qui est ce type
d'élection de mode de scrutin pour les
élections législatives
il faut peut-être réfléchir quelques
fois tout ça et c'est dire que c'est
peut-être pas le meilleur système du
monde un mot sur la réforme territoriale
qui est cité au fond comme le symbole de
la région structures comme la réforme au
fond qu'est ce qu'il aurait fallu faire
comme réforme je pense que ce qu avait
esquissé et dieu sait si je suis pas
quelquefois plutôt sévère avec nicolas
sarkozy mais il avait esquissé la fusion
de départements et des régions que nous
demandons d'ailleurs avec françois
bayrou depuis maintenant très très
longtemps avec la naissance de ce
conseil territorial et territoriaux
c'était la bonne idée c'était la bonne
piste bien évidemment la gauche est
arrivée elle a supprimé presque un des
trucs qui était bien que que la droite
avait fait qu'ils étaient bien et qu'on
aurait dû évidemment garder fusionner
départements et régions ce qui est
intelligent là la manière dont à
redécouper les régions honnêtement elle
ne fait pas sens jeu j'espère qu'il n'y
a pas d'arrière pensée clientéliste
électoral dans ce découpage j'espère
vraiment parce que ya pas de sens on met
ensemble des régions qui ont pas la même
histoire qui n'ont pas la même culture
qui n'ont pas la même identité je pense
au grand sud ouest qui re découper un
peu n'importe comment on laisse par
contre je pense à la région centre des
régions tout seul donc on fait ces
espèces de découpage à la carte qui à
mon avis n'est pas clair aux yeux des
français d'une heure et est l'intention
d'ailleurs de françois hollande cette
carte là où est-ce que c'est pas aussi
le lot du président la république qu'on
imagine sans doute trop puissant par
rapport à ses pouvoirs réels on va
continuer à en parler dans un petit
instant je vous rappelle la question du
jour le grand référendum autour de cette
question françois hollande doit-il se
représenter en 2017 vous pouvez encore
voter pendant quelques minutes un sur
sud radio point fr et on attend vos
appels 0 826 trois cents 300 15 centimes
la minute a tout de suite
sud radio dimitri pavlenko
legrand referenda le grand référendum
sud radio faut-il que françois hollande
se représente en 2010 est oui ou non
vous votez sur sud radio point fr où
vous nous appelez au 0 826 trois cents
300 bonjour guillaume bonjour quand
pensez vous est ce que c'est une bonne
idée françois hollande doit-il soir
et donc j'ai envie de vous dire que que
face aux doubiens pps etc je m'en fiche
totalement et comme vous avez des
invités politiques je veux leur répondre
sur une chose de quel droit cette
personne ne parlait de chômage contre
l'autre côté c'est qu'un exemple parmi
tant d'autres on autorise à apporter des
produits alimentaires qu'on peut
produire nous-mêmes et compressé
redévelopper dans nos apiculteurs effet
une petite souffrance ne fonde donc on
va s'arrêter alors partie des
propositions il va traiter l'actualité
moi je n'aurai qu'une chose c'est
pouvoir avoir les politiques en face de
moi pour leur poser des questions qui
dérangent vers des vérités pouvoir les
contredire
vous sentez pas écouté guillaume vous
sentez pas vous n'avez pas l'impression
que l'électeur intéresse tant que sales
et les représentants politiques c'est ça
vous y allez fort alors c'est vrai que
marielle de sarnez que dit avec beaucoup
de violence guillaume ça c'est le
ressenti aussi qu'aujourd'hui beaucoup
de français cette déconnexion entre les
français d'un côté les politiques de
l'autre comme s'il y avait un fossé
quelque part entre les deux c'est quand
même très alors que les élus sont censés
venir du peuple même les élus peuvent
pas non plus tout régler
aujourd'hui on attendait police un plan
la question ont en tous les cas ils
devraient faire leur boulot plus et être
davantage dans l'efficacité les réponses
qu'on peut apporter et donc pas non plus
faire croire qu'ils peuvent répondre à
tous c'est ça le truc après cela la
question qui nous est posée là dans ce
moment de colère que je comprends c'est
sur la question au fond de tout ce que
tout ce que nous importons et qui vient
d'autres pays certains produits
agricoles par exemple qui vont arriver
sur notre marché moins cher que ce qu'on
produit parce que c'est dû à un dumping
social un dumping fiscal et qu'il ya des
produits de moindre qualité de ce point
de vue là il a z'ont et moi je crois que
c'est quelque chose que je défends
depuis longtemps pour la france et pour
l'europe qu'il faut le laisser rentrer
dans les frontières à l'intérieur des
frontières européennes marché intérieur
aux européennes peu des produits qui
sont qui ont les mêmes normes que les
produits que nous fabriquons mes prières
de sarnez donc on a juste pour finir
aucune parce que l'on parle d'un sujet
concret pour qu'il n'y ait pas de
concurrence déloyale mais ce que je veux
dire de la volonté politique et ça veut
dire aussi pardonnez moi je finis à ma
phrase que c'est pas la france tout seul
qui peut le décider et ça veut dire que
ça on doit le décider ensemble au sein
de l'union européenne
mais est ce que le président de la
république finalement on le voit pas
comme plus puissant qu'il n'est en
réalité ben ça c'est une décision que
vous pouvez prendre si les chefs d'état
et de gouvernement considère que oui
effectivement il faut peut-être arrêter
moi je considère que bien sûr qu'on est
dans un monde ouvert bien sûr qu'il faut
que le commerce international fonctionne
mais en même temps quand je vois les
américains il défend les intérêts des
américains quand je vois les chinois y
défendre les intérêts des chinois et des
produits chinois mais moi je dis que
l'europe doit faire exactement la même
chose qu'elle doit défendre les intérêts
des européens et que quelquefois ça
n'est pas fait suffisamment alexis
bachelet est ce que justement la même
question est ce qu'on n'imagine pas le
président de la république et donc
françois hollande plus puissant qui
n'est en réalité des choses qu'il ne
peut pas régler qu'on aimerait bien
qu'il règle mais s'est jamais aussi
simple que ça finalement non mais c'est
évident que dans notre pays il ya des
attentes considérables
en direction en particulier du président
de la république parce qu'il est la clé
de voûte nos institutions et qu'il est
élu au suffrage universel direct mais
également envers les élus moi je
comprends tout à fait que
les nos concitoyens soit exigeant envers
lui même pas ce que fait qu'ils ne
votent plus depuis 20 ans ça fait 20 ans
qu'ils votent plus il ya plein de
français dans son cas on voit le taux
d'abstention dans le doubs la près de
60% des électeurs qui n'ont pas les
beautés écoutez là dessus moi j'ai un
discours aussi qui est un petit peu je
comprends que les citoyens soient
exigeants envers les élus mais on a
aussi le droit de dire la vérité à nos
concitoyens il ya adapté dans le monde
où on n'a pas le droit de vote il ya un
tas de pays dans le monde où les gens
soient emprisonnés pour leurs idées et
non pas le droit effectivement
d'exprimer ce que vient d'exprimer votre
votre auditeurs honneur qui vient de
dire il peut le dire parce que dans un
pays il est dans un pays parce qu'il ya
des gens cités se sont battus pour qu'on
instaure une démocratie et le droit de
vote excusez moi de le rappeler il est
universel depuis 1945 avant les femmes
n'avaient pas le droit de vote pendant
longtemps donc les gens croient qu'ils
ne votent pas j'ai envie de leur dire
regardez aussi un petit peu ce qui se
passe en dehors de la france et dites
vous quand même que on est dans un pays
libre et que c'est une chance de pouvoir
choisir bombo terminer les missions et
alexis bachelet très rapidement sur la
question du jour françois hollande
doit-il se représenter en 2010 s'est
très rapidement oui non vous pensez
qu'il faut qu'il soit candidat à sa
succession en 2017 écoutez honnêtement
je pense que la question est pas
aujourd'hui à l'ordre du jour on à moi
j'ai dit tout à l'heure à quel point le
contexte l'écrire constance pouvait
peser sur ce type de décision donc je
crois que le moment n'est pas venu de
savoir si françois hollande est candidat
ou non à sa succession je pense que il
le peut et il doit l'être mais en
attendant il ya encore énormément de
travail à faire au service des français
sur un essai en obtenant des résultats
notamment sur le terrain économique mais
pas seulement en faisant aussi les
propositions pour françois hollande a
jugé sur son bilan évidemment il ya
encore deux ans deux ans et demi pour
cela marianne 2 1 et ce très rapidement
oui non françois hollande doit-il se
retrouvent les millions de français dont
je vous ai parlé tout à l'heure ils
n'ont pas envie du match retour ils ont
pas envie d'un nouveau match hollande
sarkozy donc ça nous a mis très par
marine le pen moi j'ai envie de
travailler à autre chose et ben voilà
donc je veux dans les résultats du
sondage sur sud radio point fr fera la
question françois hollande doit-il oui
ou non se représenter en 2017 vous dites
non à 67% défiance envers l'actuel
président la république exprimée par
ceux qui ont voté sur sud radio point fr
merci marielle de sarnez d'avoir été
avec nous ce matin députée européenne
modem merci à vous aussi alexis bachelet
député ps de la première